Dan Crenshaw who I also sat down with
last week he was on CNN talking to Dana
Bash about what we can do to avoid some
of this stuff
the one through line in these deaths is
that they are shootings therefore they
are done by guns and Guns are the
leading cause of death for children and
teens in the U.S so shouldn't helping
save the lives
of children be a top priority for you as
a member of the House Majority
no it absolutely should be which is why
I say I would look to the thing that
would absolutely stop this which is
putting armed police officers at every
school I visit a lot of schools I do I
do talks at various schools it's very
rare that I go into a school especially
the newer ones and they don't have some
kind of armed police presence there at
all times so that's a preventive measure
that I know will stop this and there was
nothing like that in these last few mass
shootings there's no armed guards there
um so the answer is I'm just looking for
actual solutions that would be it so the
answer is more guns no the answer is
armed guards well the answer is armed
guards right armed guard yes the kind of
guns of the protect the president that
protect you all at CNN is it easy to get
into your headquarters at CNN absolutely
not there's armed guards there there's
single points of Entry I think we should
look at our schools as a place that is
precious uh and and have the same kind
of security that your corporate office
is do that we do in Congress you know if
we consider a place to be important
where our children go to learn every day
it should have the same level of
security as every other place whether
it's about whether it's a shopping mall
or a corporate office that's hard to get
into you're not going to get rid of guns
absolutely great answer by Crenshaw and
I love the fact that he turned it
directly on her what kind of security do
you have at CNN headquarters guess what
there are guys with guns there and an
awful lot of them and Gail King uh your
best friend is Oprah do you not think
Oprah has many people the only reason
anyone knows you is because of Oprah do
you not think that Oprah has many armed
guards at her many many Estates
protecting her but for some reason we
don't want that for kids again
I think there's a psychological element
that we'd really have to think through
about having young people around guns
all the time
um you know does it does it train their
mind in a weird way but certainly the
Republicans are not doing nothing and
the way oh so your answer is you just
want more guns
it's just so profoundly dishonest it is
just incredible and again what they are
really trying to do is just take the
guns here that it doesn't matter they
don't care about the dead Christian
children they they don't care whether it
was six people or a hundred people
everything is used to attain power for
these people there there is nothing they
wouldn't they I mean in essence they're
dancing on their graves that's because
they see this as an opportunity I'm
sorry if that sounds cynical it's just
how it is foreign
[Music]